hi there my name is Katherine Kwan and
I'm a developer advocate on the Google
developer relations team I'm here today
with a gift idea for you for this
upcoming Valentine's Day or the next
special occasion that's around the
corner
the idea is that you can create a mobile
app for your special someone so you can
go run and tell them I made this just
for us in today's fast-paced world you
can buy the most extravagant present
with a click of a button but sometimes
the most meaningful things are the
things you can't buy off-the-shelf they
are the things that you can create with
yourself and add a personal touch too
because after all you're the one who
knows your loved one best and how to
melt their heart you'll download the
source code for the app customize it and
then give it as a gift you're at
Valentine now keep in mind that it can
be for anyone important in your life
your significant other parent best
friend etc so let's walk through the app
it contains a list of coupons where each
one can be redeemed for a favor or some
event to do together for example you can
have a coupon to wake up insanely early
and go watch a sunrise together you
could have a coupon for a getaway to
Hawaii or a picnic at a vineyard these
are just some examples the only rule is
to be as creative as you can be whenever
the person is ready to redeem the coupon
they'll click on it and the share dialog
will pop up they can pick which app they
want to use to contact you to redeem it
there will be a pre-populated message
and photo from the coupon so that you
can just hit Send then it's up to you to
fulfill your end of the bargain if they
want a more public way of declaring how
lucky they are to have such a thoughtful
person like you in their life then they
can share to G+ or other apps as well
let's get into the steps of how to
customize the app first you can create a
custom app icon Roman Nurik who is a
fellow developer advocate on the team
created this custom tool where you can
insert a photo of you and your Valentine
into this
it will generate the icon for you and
all the right densities when you open up
the tool you'll see a blank heart then
upload your image of your choice either
a picture of you two or the picture of
an adorable puppy you can adjust the
scaling and padding of the image as well
so it looks centered once you create
your app icon you can download the zip
file of the icons and save it for later
now you'll want to download the code for
the app you'll need Android studio to
open the app if you haven't installed it
before see the link for how to set up
Android studio once your looking at the
code you should fill in the sender name
with your name that way when the coupon
is shared to another app the sentence
will contain your name too like in this
example I'm excited to redeem my coupon
with ami just to add a personal touch to
it next you'll want to add photos for
your own coupons in the assets folder
where the other images are located
here's a screenshot of what the assets
folder looks like an Android studio now
you can just add the lines of code to
create the coupons specify a title a
description and the name of the
corresponding image file in the assets
folder after you're done customizing it
you can give it to your Valentine you
can use Google Play to make it available
to them optionally you can restrict the
app availability using the Alpha Channel
feature in Google Play we've given you
the basics but you can extend it further
think of new ways you can bond with this
person by taking advantage of what a
phone can offer your phone can buzz when
the other person is thinking of you if
you hook it up to a web service you can
send them little notes or pictures to
their device so start brainstorming and
be the first one to build a personal app
for your loved one that should earn you
some major brownie points you can share
screen shots of the app that you build
with the hashtag just for us and it will
give other people ideas on what to do
too
thanks for watching and I can't wait to
see what you build